this question of what the US
relationship with Israel ought to look
like and this is something I think about
a lot because sometimes I get frustrated
with our fellow traveler Libertarians
for I think sometimes seeming a little
unrealistic on matters of foreign policy
I think there is frequently a sense of
what the US should do aspirationally but
then there also needs to be a sense
of what the US should do in order to
taper off an existing relationship
recognize that you know cutting off ties
or cutting off any sort of funding of
Israel is not something that can
realistically happen overnight and that
there would be massive second order
consequences that would stem from that
if that did happen how do you look at
this relationship between the US and
Israel and and this us support for
Israel how do you look at it
aspirationally in terms of what that
relationship ought to be like but also
more
practically uh it's a tricky question um
I know it's a big question and you're
not a foreign policy expert but I'm just
curious about how your views on this
have evolved over time was I'm not an
expert but I often play one on TV so
I'll do the best I can
um the United States gives about three
billion I think dollars a year to Israel
give a similar amount to Egypt uh at
least until recently
maybe uh that is not free money it is
credits it's $3 billion doll of credits
that
the U that um Israel has to use in the
US military grocery store meaning it's
for purchasing Us weapons aircraft Etc
uh so it it is a um a subsidy both to
Israel and the US uh defense industry
defense industry and
um historically I've never been in favor
of that Aid uh I've always opposed it I
don't think it's good for Israel
particularly we're now a very rich
country when it was first started we
were pretty poor country Israel has a
pretty high standard of living we can
pay for our own equipment if we want I'm
happy I hope the US will continue to
sell it to us I think the trickier part
of the relationship is
um what's happening right now so right
now uh there are two aircraft carriers
uh in the Eastern side of the
Mediterranean and a nuclear submarine
and they're there mainly to threaten
Iran and Iran's uh friend Hezbollah and
to say don't think about opening up a
second front against Israel or we'll
punish
you um that's been really helpful to us
more or less here in Israel not clear
whether we we do have a nuclear weapon
here
um that carries a lot of weight but it's
a threat you never want to carry out
so I don't know what this would look
like right now if the US had not made
that implicit threat and I'm sure they
made some explicit threats behind the
scenes that we don't know about so
that's for helpful to Israel uh having
said that I I think it's a legitimate
question for Americans to ask whether
that serves the interest of the United
States there are many Jews Evangelical
Christians and others who see Israel in
a very special light different from many
other other
countries but whether the average uh
American taxpayer should be funding the
uh ability of the United States to still
act as something of the world's
policemen I think is a is a complicated
question if Israel had to stand on its
own uh it would have to devote a lot
more of its resources to the mil its own
military which it devotes a significant
amount already but it would have to
devote more and it would set in motion a
whole bunch of things some of them would
be good for Israel and some not so good
uh a lot of people would argue that this
moment has taught us that Israel cannot
defend itself alone that it needs the
United States to be a counterweight to
to Iran and that may be true so I I
think it's going to be very interesting
to see how this evolves over the next
few
years um and whether any President Biden
whoever wins uh the next election would
carry out threats like uh that are being
implied against Iran and risk a world
war with with Russia which is Iran's um
Ally and and the rest of the Middle East
it's
um it's pretty um pretty challenging
yeah you know what concerns me about the
relationship between the US and Israel a
it's not an unconditional support but it
is a very
substantial like we've got your back
kind of thing and and I'm I'm morally
supportive of the right of Israel's
govern government to defend its people
against this kind of atrocity and to
seek Justice and rescue the hostages and
dismantle Hamas to the extent that can
be done what I've been uncomfortable
with and become increasingly so is any
us Aid in that project because Israel's
military is having to make really
difficult moral calculations and
tradeoffs about how many soldiers
they're willing to sacrif I in ground
operations versus how many civilian
casualties to accept with other types of
you know aerial bombings and they're not
easy calls and frankly they're not
always calls that I agree with and the
more the US has culpability in that with
its its funding you know the worst all
around on all sides that is in my view
it it's it's Israel's fight and the
government of Israel is is seems capable
of Prosecuting it and I wonder it when
you're talking about you know the the
difference in Israel's interests and
America's
interests is
America do you do you think America is
in some sense
tying Israel's hands in ways that makes
it harder to defend itself well it cuts
both ways right
um I I think America's Embrace of Israel
the government's embrace the military's
Embrace of Israel is um has cost for the
United States uh those costs may be
worth bearing for other
benefits they may be worth bearing for
moral
reasons it's not an easy question to
answer I would just add that a friend of
mine said the other day that the Embrace
of the United States of Israel is more
like a bear
hug it um it doesn't just show love and
affection it also constrains Israel a
great deal uh many of those constraints
we would impose on ourselves here
certainly with respect to civilian
casualties but uh historically often
Israel
has gone along with what the United
States wanted because there's a feeling
here that we need the United States so
if we couldn't rely on that we would
behave differently and that would be
both good and bad I suspect thanks for
listening to our conversation with Russ
Roberts for the full
go here for more Clips go here